bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france sont aux coûts
ironisé sur le fait que cela fait
longtemps maintenant que la russie est
soupçonné d'être sur le point d'envahir
l'ukraine est ce qu'il est pertinent de
se demander à qui profite cette crise
qui dure gérard ollivier
gérald
qu'il faut il faut raison garder dans ce
contexte parce que les états unis et la
russie sont toujours des adversaires
mais l'enjeu n'est plus existentielles
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre nous ne
sommes plus au temps de la guerre froide
ou non seulement deux pays mais de
système et de ski des au logis
s'opposaient et la victoire de l'as
impliquait la disparition de l'autre
aujourd'hui les états unis n'ont plus
d'autre intérêt vital en ukraine que le
fait que ce pays puisse jouir de sa
souveraineté nationale et que son
intégrité territoriale soient respectés
ça ne va pas au delà alors la question
de la sécurité de l'ukraine évidemment
pose problème parce que d'un côté le
cren voudrait bien le parapluie de
l'otan ce qu'il assurerait de ne jamais
rien craindre de son voisin quand même
beaucoup plus puissant que la russie et
de l'autre l'admirent poutine la russie
considère qu'une adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan serait une ligne rouge qui
impliquerait une réponse semble de
nature militaire donc je pense que
malheureusement on il faut soutenir
l'attention et attendre que les choses
je dirais retombe un petit peu et
envisager plutôt une solution quelques
celles qui concernent aussi bien la
finlande ou la suède qui sont des pays
voisins de la russie et qui ne sont pas
nécessairement membre de l'otan et qui
ne se sont pas néanmoins menacée par la
russie donc l'indépendance de l'ukraine
est quand même un épisode qui reste tout
à fait récent remonte à une trentaine
d'années les choses ne sont pas apaisées
c'est un pays qui possède une importante
population russe et qui doit respecter à
la fois l'héritage et de la culture de
cette population je pense que la
situation est très différente de celle
que nous avions avec la crimée parce que
l'histoire de ces deux pays n'est pas la
même y compris l'histoire récente est
donc pour l'instant c'est juste une
montée de tension qui à mon avis reste
une crise diplomatique dont l' issue
diplomatique demeure plus que probable
quelle est la situation en termes de
politique intérieure justement en
ukraine nicholas markowitz le président
ukrainien est au pouvoir depuis deux ans
maintenant il avait été élu on s'en
souvient sur sa promesse à la fois de
lutter contre la corruption sur la
promesse aussi de faire la paix dans le
donbass l'est de l'ukraine où un conflit
oppose à des séparatistes au
gouvernement de kiev vladimir poutine à
d'ailleurs estimé dans la journée que la
situation rappeler un génocide il a
évoqué la russophobie dont sont victimes
les populations locales est ce qu'on
peut faire un lien entre la gestion du
pouvoir du président ukrainien volodimir
felinski ce focus qu'il fait sur moscou
malheureusement oui pour regarder les
résultats de zazen ce qui depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir il avait promis de
ramener la paix au donbass il avait
promis de lutter contre la corruption il
avait promis de d'éviter que le des
milliers centaines des milliers
d'ukrainiens fui et qui reste en ukraine
pour on pourra trouver du travail
aujourd'hui le résultat est piètre il
est très mauvais le taux d'inflation
aujourd'hui en ukraine est à 11% les
investissements directs étrangers sont
négatifs c'est à dire que les capitaux
qui sont arrivés en ukraine puis
l'ukraine et aujourd'hui on part de
bruits de bottes sur la frontière il ya
une tension réelle aux dons basse et le
bilan de zelensky et très mauvais nous
n'oublions pas que washington est un des
premiers états qui dénoncent aujourd'hui
donc c'est un des plus grands alliés de
l'ukraine dénonce aujourd'hui la
corruption rampante aujourd'hui malgré
la présence de leur chouchou zelensky au
pouvoir de zine ce qui n'arrive pas à
mettre en place son programme c'est un
échec la la la la corruption continue il
ya toujours des menaces de guerre en
ukraine et on a l'impression que la
seule chose zielinski peut trouver pour
essayer de rassembler des ukrainiens ont
essayé de se faire bien voir justement
par washington et bien c'est de
maintenir à foyers de tension sur la
frontière russe on sait que les faucons
de guerre de l'otan aime beaucoup ce
foyer de tension il ya énormément
d'activités des na'vi d dion de l'otan
des navires de l'otan sur la frontière
russo des exercices ces dernières années
avec plus de trente mille soldats de
lente de l'otan dans des pays
limitrophes de la dola de la russie dans
l'otan cherche la provocation je pense
qu'ils aimeraient bien que la russie
perde son sang-froid et tombe dans le
piège que la russie ne fait pas pour
l'instant la seule façon que trouve
zelensky pour essayer de sortir de cette
situation on va dire politiquement
mauvaise sa cote de popularité est au
plus bas eh bien ces deux d'attiser un
peu là la fibre patriotique en dénonçant
moscou comme si moscou était responsable
de tous ces maux alors que le seul
responsable des maux du prennent
aujourd'hui bien il faut le dire c'est
hélène ce qui a mis la situation le pays
dans cette situation vous êtes encore
gérald olivier avec cette idée selon
laquelle il ya un contexte intérieur un
terreau favorable dont profitent des
acteurs extérieurs à la région comme les
états unis puis l'otan aussi
je pense que les deux leaders jours
exactement la même carte parce que bon
jour je ne crois pas aux provocations de
l'otan ce n'est pas du tout l'intérêt de
l'otan de provoquer une intervention
russe aujourd'hui en ukraine dans la
mesure où il n'y a rien il n'y a aucun
accord de sécurité qui obligerait l'otan
à intervenir en ukraine donc la
situation sera catastrophique si c'était
le cas non je pense que les deux leaders
jouent sur la veine populiste et
vladimir poutine aussi la des meilleures
poutines aime bien présente et
l'occident les etats-unis l'europe comme
des puissances qui sont toujours hostile
à la russie à la russie historique à la
russie d'aujourd'hui il aime bien jouer
sur la veine nationaliste et on sait
très bien que il y à des nationalistes
russes en ukraine dont il a une excuse
pour le faire mais dans cette situation
faut pas se tromper d'agresseurs c'est à
dire que le cren c'est le petit dans
l'histoire et l'otan n'a pas de lien de
sécurité aujourd'hui des n'accorde
sécurité avec l'ukraine ça fait 30 ans
que l'ukraine demande à rentrer dans
l'otan ils ne sont pas encore membres de
ce qu'on appelle le plan d'action est
pour l'instant il n'y a sur la table des
négociations l'otan aucunement une
candidature de l'ukraine considéré de
mai sérieuse n'a été faite
geraldo lévis on apprend à l'instant
l'otan rejette le veto de moscou sur une
éventuelle adhésion de l'ukraine la
dépêche de l'agencé france presse je
viens tout juste de tomber mais que ce
serait oui votre regard de l'allée des
justes pour terminer par rapport à cette
dépêche ou c'est parfaitement normal
parce que les règles des règles de
l'otan disent qu'il n'appartient pas à
un pays extérieurs à l'otan de dictée
qui peut rentrer une parente rick donc
il était parfaitement logique que le
temps fasse ce genre de de communiqué
maintenant encore une fois je pense que
les deux leaders jouent sur une certaine
veine nationaliste qu'on a une poussée
de tension que les troupes pour les
troupes russes sont bien là et que dans
le cas d'un conflit entre l'ukraine et
la russie la question de savoir qui
serait le vainqueur laisse assez peu de
doute donc il n'est pas du tout dans
l'intérêt l'ukrainien de pousser trop
loin la provocation
nicholas markowitz comment est ce que
vous vous accueillez cette annonce de
l'otan est ce que vous vous diriez que
le temps profite d'un contexte pour
encourager kiev quelles sont ses
intentions selon vous oui je moi je
pense au contraire que le temps profiter
le temps cherchent à provoquer et si le
temps en effet n'a pas d'accord avec le
créneau aujourd'hui il faut pas oublier
que ce sont quand même des pays membres
de l'otan qui sont en train d'inspecter
les troupes du craignent-elles sur la
ligne de front dont basse c'est sont les
états unis qui ont débloqué un budget de
500 millions de dollars d aide militaire
à l'ukraine ce sont des entraîneurs
américains et malheureusement aussi
d'autres pays de l'otan qui sont en
ukraine pour former les soldats
ukrainien au kiné cette hypocrisie de
dire que l'otan ne s'impliquerait pas
dans l'un des problèmes de l'ukraine
paiera pas d'accord et en même temps
d'envoyer des soldats de l'otan forme et
armés là le soleil crinière donc du coup
bien sûr que le temps que ça parce qu'au
sein même de l'otan il y a beaucoup de
personnes dans la hiérarchie qui pensent
qu'ils ne savent pas que la guerre
froide est terminée et qu'ils veulent à
tout prix cette situation de tension on
ne fait je pense la russie n'a aucun
intérêt à voir une guerre aucun intérêt
du tout la russie le développer les
commerces la russie a développé avec
l'ordre de l'ouest de nombreuses
sociétés européennes le 'pipeline' nord
stream 2 qui devrait être lancée c'est
l'intérêt de l'est de la russie qui
veulent faire tomber les sanctions et
sanctions à imposer les sanctions
économiques imposées par des pays de
l'otan donc du coup c'est pas la russie
qui est là la russie plutôt que la
victime dans cette histoire parce que du
coup ce sont les pays membres de l'otan
qui n'arrêtent pas d'imposer sa tension
qui vont faire des patrouilles
militaires sur la frontière sur les
frontières russes et qui essaient y
d'attiser cette situation dont basse
n'oublions pas que si des pays membres
de l'otan voulait la paix deux pays
membre de l'otan la france et
l'allemagne sont co signataire des
accords de minsk 2 qui vise la paix aux
gambas ces accords de paix de 2005 2
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'entend jamais la
france et l'allemagne en parler où sont
les responsables politiques français et
allemands qui leur en ukraine pour
rappeler des obligations à l'ukraine ses
obligations de paix pourquoi est ce que
c'est les différentes bases éléments de
cet accord de minsk 2 ne sont pas mises
en place et pourquoi est ce que les pays
membres de l'otan ne met pas la pression
sur l'ukraine pour qu'elles respectent
ces accords au lieu d'envoyer des
soldats des troupes des armes les pays
membres de l'otan notamment en tout cas
la france est le mal serait mieux
d'utiliser leur force diplomatique et
leurs moyens pour rappeler à kiev ces
obligations pour trouver une solution
pacifique dans le donbass quelles sont
les intentions réelles des états unis
dans cette escalade des tensions gérald
olivier washington qui effectivement
remet dans le jeu le gazoduc north
stream ii entre la russie l'allemagne et
l'utilisent comme levier comme moyen de
pression vis-à-vis de moscou
justement non les états unis ne
l'utilisent pas comme moyen de pression
parce que les sanctions auxquelles mon
collègue faisait allusion il ya quelques
minutes elles sont été levée par
l'administration by dingue alors certes
à l'heure actuelle ce seul ce gazoduc
north stream 2 il n'est pas en opération
d'accord mais le l'obstacle qui avait
été mise en place par le congrès
américain sous forme de sanction de
grâce contre gazprom ces sanctions ont
été levées au printemps et les états
unis ont donné un feu vert principe à ce
que ce cet oléoduc entre en activité ce
qui d'ailleurs est relativement
incohérent parce que une fois que cet
oléoduc fonctionnement et bien l'ukraine
sera privé d'un certain nombre revenu à
travers les droits de transit du gaz qui
passe par les pipelines qui traversent
son propre territoire donc là les états
unis ont tiré un petit peu dans le quai
de leurs alliés si l'ukraine est
véritablement leurs alliés dans la
situation parce qu'ils vont leur priver
de revenus qui sont relativement
importants mais ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que aujourd'hui le cren n'est pas
un intérêt stratégique vital des états
unis aujourd'hui l'intérêt stratégique
vital des états unis il se situe sur le
théâtre de l'inde au pacifique il se
situe vis-à-vis de la chine la menace
existentielle pour la chine 21e siècle
ce n'est plus la russie de vladimir
poutine s'est lassé lashing de chip jean
ping est ce que la politique américaine
au cours des 15 dernières années
consiste justement à se désengager d'un
certain nombre de théâtres et ça c'est
une politique qui marque une certaine
continuité d'une administration
démocrate à une administration
républicaine à une autre administration
démocrate se désengager d'un certain
nombre de théâtre y compris
l'afghanistan tenue dernièrement pour
justement avoir les mains libres et
pouvoir se concentrer sur ce qui pour
eux est la menace principale qui est
celle que pose la chine communiste en
termes démographiques en termes
économiques en termes technologiques et
en termes militaires vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la région de naples indo
pacifique donc les états unis n'ont
aucun intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un
conflit autour du donbass en ukraine et
ils n'ont aucune intention de s'engager
au delà de la fourniture d'armes et d'un
appui je dirais diplomatique dans un
conflit potentiel et je vous laisse
répondre nicolas mercat vais te laissera
le mot de la fin je pense que je les
fais l'ennemi principal des états unis
c'est clairement la chine pour autant
les etats-unis ne se désengage pas de
cette région n'oublions pas que ce sont
quand même les états unis qui sont
derrière l'évolution de l'euro maidan
victorienne hollande qui a encore dans
l'administration by donne aujourd'hui à
l'époque avait avoué que les états unis
avaient dépensé de l'argent pour
apporter la démocratie en ukraine et que
c'est suite à cette révolution de
couleur et du changement brutal de
gouvernement à kiev ce que nous avons lu
ces tensions en ukraine qui sont
exacerbées et qui ont mené à la guerre
civile c'est quand même moi schouten qui
est derrière tu tapes leurs médailles
vous avez le patron de la cia qui
débarque le patron de la cia qui
débarque en ukraine si les étés depuis
ce temps là on voit très bien les la
main de washington dans l'organisation
de l'administration a deux hatier f quel
que soit le président que ce soit pour
chiots aujourd'hui zelensky je pense que
peut-être que les états unis dans une
vision plus long est ce le grand
échiquier vont monnayer l'ukraine avec
la russie c'est possible pour autant les
américains löw tente que les américains
le gouvernement byden aujourd'hui les
soldats de l'otan sont bien présents
autour de la zone du donbass ils sont
présents en mer noire les avions de
l'otan patrouillent le long des
frontières russes clairement on essaie
de mettre la pression sur la russie
peut-être pourra-t-on manning en tout
cas ça plait ça peut ça peut espérer d
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver il
ya encore quelques jours à la un avion
de ligne avec des civils russes a failli
percuter un avion espion allemands vda
paix de l'otan un incident comme ça qui
peut déclencher une guerre et selon
l'accord entre différentes puissances
nucléaires je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et que washington
ferait mieux de faire très attention
parce que du coup ça il ya un brazy
potentiel dans cette région là s'il
était sincère il quitterait l'endroit et
laisseront la diplomatie il laisserait
la diplomatie la place et retirerait les
troupes à ce que ces diplomatiquement
qui doivent régler le problème au cou
merci nicolas mirkovic analystes
politiques merci à vous également gérald
ollivier journaliste franco américain
chercheurs à ali ps